[Music]
ever think of how many breaths of air
you take in a day it's a lot like twenty
thousand give or take a few all day all
night our bodies are at work bringing in
the good
and kicking out the back
but as important as this is to our very
existence there's still a lot that many
of us misunderstand about what's really
in our air
[Music]
most people don't know very much about
air pollution we don't sort of see this
invisible connection between that
pollution and very real health problems
I'm Beth Gardner I'm an environmental
journalist and author of the book choked
life and breath in the age of air
pollution
air pollution is killing millions of
people around the world the World Health
Organization estimates 7 million
annually and causing a long list of
illnesses
air pollution affects almost every
biological system in our bodies
increased rates of air pollution are
linked to higher rates of heart attacks
of Strokes of premature birth of
multiple different kinds of cancer of
Alzheimer's disease and cognitive
problems in kids diabetes and obesity
and the list just goes on and on and on
and on
the pollutant that scientists have
really honed in on in recent years as
the most worrying is called particulate
pollution if this man is continuously
exposed to this sort of atmosphere then
there will be a buildup of these
particles
particles called p
M diameter that is about a 30th of the
width of human hair PM 2.5 and even
smaller ones which are called ultrafine
are so small that they can actually
penetrate deep down into the lungs all
the way into the tiny little sacs called
alveoli where the air within our lungs
crosses into the bloodstream once
they're in the bloodstream they can
travel all around the body and impact
all of our different organs
a lot of people really associate air
pollution with cities that this is an
urban problem air doesn't know any
boundaries it doesn't stop at the city
limits these tiny particles can actually
travel thousands of miles
there are a lot of different pollutants
mostly related to burning things oil and
gas and Diesel and wood and coal and
garbage
[Music]
agriculture is another unexpected but
pretty significant contributor to air
pollution the different chemicals that
come off of fertilizers and manure
combined in the air with other
pollutants and the smell can be a real
nuisance to your neighbors there's a lot
of different things in the air whether
you're living close to the factory
miles away from them
[Music]
this is not a problem that is equally
distributed it's not just cities it's
where you're going to end up living if
you have lower housing costs the
neighborhoods that are most heavily
impacted very often are poorer people of
color immigrants people who lack the
ability to move somewhere cleaner those
tend to be the places where these really
polluting facilities get cited so this
is really a problem that tracks very
much with the fault lines of economic
inequality and racial Injustice
this one we talk about environmental
challenges and how to fix them the
conversation often gets really really
focused on what it's going to cost
in terms of Public Health productivity
longer life spans the benefits in dollar
terms of cleaner air are dozens of times
greater than the costs but of course the
costs have to be paid up front by
Industries and the benefits are reaped
years later across Society
[Music]
historically been an impressive Global
air quality success story because of
this very strong very Innovative law the
Clean Air Act supported by the way by
both Democrats and Republicans and that
started with getting lead out of the air
lead was in gasoline there's 70 percent
less pollution in the air than there was
in 1970 because of this law the lesson
that comes from that is that we know
what works this is not an impossible
problem
science-based regulations that
prioritize Public Health Works
foreign
sort of overwhelming but it's also quite
inspiring when you look at what has been
achieved so far
there are also innovative solutions in
the works to drastically reduce
pollutants before they even get into our
air
bold ideas that take us away from
burning things to clean our energy
reimagining Urban spaces that are
friendlier to bikers and pedestrians and
shifting to electric vehicles to get us
everywhere else
that kind of Ingenuity might be the
difference between breathing dirty air
now
or truly fresh air in the future
[Music]